(audience applauding)
Hi.
So good to see you.
It's so good to see you too.
I feel like we both been at this for a while.
Like, you know, okay, here's an example.
Like Andrew McCarthy is going to come on the show
and I'm reading his new book,
and he says in his chapter and on page 141,
one evening I ended up at a party and someone sweeten,
spotted a cute young woman with a pixie haircut
and a happy manner across the room.
I chatted her up, but Courteney Cox was having none of me.
This was pre-friends,
but even more impressive to me,
she had just appeared in the Bruce Springsteen video
"Dancing in the Dark", life was pretty good.
That's mostly true.
(audience laughing)
Did you?
I mean like.
No, that's true, I did meet him I remember
and I think it was at The Sunset Marquis
and he was really nice.
I do, he was really sweet
The Brat Pack, they were everything.
Brat Pack, right.
I had my first slow dance
at Emilio Estévez's birthday party,
or was it Rob Lowe's birthday party?
I can't remember.
Anyway, it's just, there's not that many people
I feel like I can chat up about those days.
Oh my gosh Drew,
I mean, you have such history, it's crazy your life
and how everything you've gone through, all the.
You have so many stories to tell,
but I am so happy to be here with you right now,
I wish I was in the same room with you
because you're the most infectious person that I know.
When I see you, all I want to do is hug you so tight,
you're so sweet,
and you're the same sweetness,
you could be so jaded
with everything you've done in your life, but I just,
every time I see you, it warms my heart.
I love this coming from you.
You could be the, A, exact same way,
and B, I do feel your love through Instagram sometimes.
Sometimes I read your comments on my feed
and I comment on your feed
and when I see that like you like something or comment,
I'm like, everything's good.
I'm glad to know that you see it
'cause I will comment more on your stuff because
I have a love, hate relationship
'cause there's pressure and it's not always nice, but
you know, I've met some nice people on Instagram.
I think, you know I've learned
social media, which I'm glad,
'cause you know, we grew up in a way where
a lot of our lives, you know, were out there
and we were hanging out with people and you know,
I had my whole life as an open book,
but I think it was such great prep for social media as.
Oh gosh, yes.
I mean the best, I worry about like kids who just have
access to social media without this sort of amazing training
and learning for yourself what is TMI,
what is your boundary,
you know, I, I love the whole picture.
And realize that it lives forever.
You have to be so careful.
I know.
I mean, that's a lesson I always try to tell Coco.
You can, you think,
I mean not that she's going to run for any government office
but you just have to be really careful,
it will, once it's up,
somehow even if you take it down, it's always there.
Oh, I think that used to matter.
I think you can kind of have done anything or do anything
and run for government office at this point.
You know, that ship has sailed.
It's true, Coco's got a shot.
Yeah, exactly.
But I digress because you talked about Coco and it's funny,
I was upstairs thinking about this interview,
this conversation, and I started crying upstairs,
and I just did because it's so funny,
excuse me, oh no, it's happening again.
I see in your daughter a lot of things
and I don't know her that well,
but I see in your daughter a lot of things
that remind me of my daughter
with her makeup and her expressiveness
and her like purple hair and her room remodels.
So I was just curious, mother to mother,
any advice you might have for me.
Well, first of all, I can imagine your daughter being,
just because you're such a fun, free spirited person
and people will say, oh, you know
why do you let Coco wears so much makeup?
She's been wearing makeup forever.
That is a self-expression for her.
She loves to dress up.
She loves, she will dye her hair,
it was purple a week ago, I think right now
it's blonde underneath and before it's blue.
I mean, we've ruined the bathroom a thousand times.
I've told her, please put down garbage bags,
she didn't get to neat gene from me, that's for sure.
First of all, sidebar, the neat gene like you,
are you Monica Geller?
Did Monica Geller like get that from you?
I am very neat.
I'm not, I'm really neat, I really am.
I mean look, I did that post that I said, you know,
how do you say you're Monica
without telling people you're Monica?
And then I opened up my drawers.
Now I'm not going to lie, those are my two best drawers.
Every drawer looks like that.
So yeah, I'm pretty neat.
I need organization and I don't clutter.
But anyways, I think we just have to let them be themselves
with boundaries of course.
I'm not great at boundaries, I need to get better at it.
But one of the most, the best threat that I'd give Coco,
I mean, I don't mean to,
I actually mean it when I say it
but it's threatening to her is,
I'm going to really start sticking to my boundaries.
And she's like, what?
You're a great mom, just don't change,
you know, I don't like change.
So if I just say I'm gonna be stricter,
just, the fear goes right in.
But the one thing you got to stick with is,
if you say, I'm taking your phone away
then you gotta be strong.
I'm not always strong, that's the key though.
My partner Johnny is always like,
you have to stick with your boundaries,
that's really important.
That's what I always heard.
Like when they were little,
is like, the follow through is crucial.
You have to follow through, you know.
I don't have like a traditional family blueprint.
(upbeat music)